thank you so my name is Joe
I'm a machine learning engineer at
atrium and the topic of this talk is
detecting sign
deep learning I think that the target
audience for this talk is they're people
who have some familiarity with machine
learning maybe you understand how a
convolutional neural network works and
you're familiar with evaluation metrics
like precision and recall so now's now's
the time to Google those if you need a
quick refresher
I think this talk is really cool because
it's an example of applying computer
vision techniques to legal documents
which is probably not that common
I think this top this talk should appeal
to anybody who's interested in applying
deep learning to a novel dataset so
first what is a trium so we've been
around for a little over a year now and
we're a tech enabled law firm we mostly
service startups and emerging companies
in the Bay Area and we have a unique
corporate structure so we created a tech
company that creates the products and
technology that the law firm consumes
and services our clients we've done away
with billable hours and we've replaced
it with a client friendly subscription
model and product and engineering focus
on building differentiating products
that deliver client value and also
unlock efficiencies for lawyers we think
a lot about attracting and hiring the
best talent and building out teams of
expert lawyers and our strategy has been
to sell to startups and scale up with
them and their needs so a little bit
more in the problems that we're trying
to solve there's several existing
problems with legal services one is that
pricing is non predictable it's often
opaque and timelines are also slow also
unpredictable and there's just a general
lack of transparency when interacting
with a corporate law firm on the machine
learning and product side specifically
we're focused on automating and
mitigating issues with legal documents
so today searching for a specific
document and then extracting the
information you need from those
documents is a time consuming an
exhaustive exhausting process
furthermore when you want to work with
aggregate information across a large
corpus of documents that generally
involves keeping track of some
spreadsheets sharing it with people
manually coming over
documents and plugging things into a
spreadsheet we're trying to replace that
we're trying to use machine learning to
turn these documents into data so what
we're focused on doing is building out a
structured metadata profile of any
document that we receive so a bit more
on what that looks like in in practice
so when we receive client documents we
apply optical character recognition and
then we apply several machine learning
operators to the document and then this
we bring a human in the loop to audit
and review both the documents themselves
as well as the outputs of the machine
learning models then we use this
structured representation for search and
retrieval of the documents in order for
both our clients and our lawyers to
perform legal tasks so that that could
be anything from a venture capital
financing and incorporation or a
contract negotiation and we use the
structured data also to generate new
documents like like a cap table for
instance and so we accomplish this with
three machine learning technologies
today the first is document
classification so we classify a document
and we use that classification to route
a document to the appropriate structured
predictor which my colleague Zach Witten
just spoke about in the last talk for
those of you that were here I'm so
structured predictions that's how we
annotate fields like counterparties and
effective dates in documents and then if
the document type is one that we expect
to require a signature we run a
signature detection operator on the
document and that's what the remainder
of this talk is going to focus on so why
do we care about signature detection
well right now manually detecting
whether or not a document is signed it
requires the time and effort of skilled
individuals namely paralegals who could
dedicate their time to more important
things
also having unsigned documents poses a
significant legal legal risk for our
clients and then another thing that
happens is when clients upload a batch
of documents some percentage of those
are going to be drafts of each other so
you can determine which which documents
are related to each other's but then you
need to be able to determine which
document is the final copy in that batch
so
presence of the signature is actually a
strong indicator of which one is final
and let's go a little bit into the
history of signature detection and some
of the literature that's out there so
banks do this with checks today but you
know they're they're fortunate enough to
work on a much more constrained problem
they're usually only ever looking for
one signature the documents are
templated you know where a signature
would appear and then outside of banks
and law firms signatures are really not
all that important from from a business
standpoint so you have there hasn't
actually been a lot of improvement in
recent years and the ability to do this
but there is a publicly available data
set called the tobacco 800 which
misleadingly actually contains almost
1300 labeled images but they've only
labeled signatures so none of them have
like unsigned labels so several papers
have been published using this data set
some of them are using the signature as
a mechanism for retrieving similar
documents others are focused on
classification but what you commonly see
is researchers will apply these somewhat
arcane either like rule-based approaches
that are specific to detecting cursive
script or they'll use some other manual
feature extraction technique and then
they'll run a classifier afterwards and
that may be a neural network it may be a
support vector machine as far as I can
tell the state of the art on detecting
signatures is ninety two point eight
percent and I haven't been able to find
a lot on detecting unsigned signature
boxes in documents so if anybody has any
experience with that I'd love to talk to
you I'd love to talk to you and for
legal documents specifically you might
be detecting an arbitrary amount of
signatures and unsigned signature boxes
and the locations where they might be in
a document can be somewhat arbitrary as
well so in addition to using the tobacco
800 data set we started out with 12,000
label documents of our own and over the
last few months we've scaled up to more
than 40,000 label document pages and
that results in 10,000 unsigned
signature boxes
and 4,000 signs signature boxes I'm some
you know one approach to solving this
problem in an appropriate method would
be using convolutional neural networks
and the simplest way to do that would be
to just do binary classification so you
would return a probability distribution
for whether or not the document is
signed that's actually the first
approach we took just just to see what
kind of results we could get so if
you're not familiar with convolutional
neural networks I'll give a quick
high-level description the the basic
idea is and the network is applying
these fixed size filters that stride
across the the image and they're applied
to the RGB channels of the image and
then they're computing a nonlinear
activation the way a standard neural
network would the there's also a
operation called max pooling that allows
you to down sample the data by selecting
the max value in some fixed region then
generally at the end of the network
you'll have a fully connected layer
after this you've extracted all of the
features you need in order to make a
classification I'm so to that extent you
can think of the hierarchical layers and
in the network is the earlier layers are
learning sort of simple shapes edges
things like that and then the the hope
is that the later layers will be
learning more complex things like how to
detect handwriting and hopefully how to
detect signature boxes so now that we're
starting to get into deep learning I
want to address a few kind of common
misconceptions about deep learning the
first is that doing deep learning
requires large amounts of data this has
become you know this was true at one
time this has become less true because
you transfer learning has take taken off
there's a lot of large publicly
available datasets that you could use to
augment your own data and there's also a
lot of pre trained neural networks that
are that are published that you can
transfer it on top of if you're not
familiar with transfer learning I'll
define that in the next slide and the
other is that it requires deep expertise
so this is this is kind of true I don't
I don't believe that it requires any
more expertise than either
roaches and it's just that you're
shifting where you need that expertise
so instead of having to learn like
manual pre-processing techniques that
are very specific to the problem you're
trying to solve you just operate on raw
inputs so you know now you're having to
build more expertise in some open source
library that's pretty hard to use
compared to scikit-learn and then the
final misconception that I often hear is
that only big companies have the data
and the compute in order to do this I
think this is another one that's really
changed in the last year there's a rich
ecosystem of startups now that are
helping companies scale up data labeling
operations as well as giving affordable
access to two GPUs to train on so I
mentioned this concept of transfer
learning so I want to sort of get into
the intuition behind that so we
mentioned that the earlier layers in a
network are learning very simple things
like shapes and and colors and edges
well it turns out those are pretty
common to all computer vision problems
and so the intuition is and it's been
shown that you can actually get better
performance out of a neural network if
you train on a massive general dataset
so something that has lots of classes of
images lots of representation for each
class and then you freeze the earlier
layers in the network and you change the
output to better that the output layer
to better represent the problem that
you're trying to solve and you just
update the weights on the last few
layers so this greatly reduces the time
it takes to train a model a model
reduces the amount of data that you need
and all in all it's just a less volatile
experience so what you've started to see
is it's less common to train a custom
neural network from scratch just just
because of the difficulty associated
with that versus doing transfer learning
but we did mostly for the sake of like
benchmarking just to see what kind of
performance we could get we did attempt
to use a custom neural network to do
binary classification so I define this
network it's got a soft max output that
returns a probability distribution of
whether or not the page is signed or not
it's pretty standard we use 3x3
convolutions 2x2 max pooling and we use
ray liotta visions and it actually gets
really good results we're able to get
above 90% accuracy of classifying
whether or not a page is signed but
there's only one problem with this
approach which is consider the case
where you have one signature present on
a page and you're able to detect it but
you're also missing another signature so
a binary classifier would actually
return you know this document is signed
because it's detected a signature so
these gray boxes that you see on the
image that's just me like anonymizing
people's names and stuff like that in
the in the document so what we actually
want to be able to do is to be able to
localize to class's signature boxes
which contain a signature and unsigned
signature boxes so what we actually want
the neural network to give us is a class
label for what we're detecting and we
want an x and y coordinate of the
midpoint and a height and width for the
bounding box surrounding that object so
you might be asking how does this change
the architecture of the neural network
I'm working with well it turns out not a
lot not a lot changes so we're changing
the output to give us a confidence of
whether or not an object is detected the
X and y coordinate and the height then
width of the bounding box and then a
distribution of the class label now I've
simplified this a little bit because
what you're actually doing is you're
going to partition the image into into a
grid and the network is actually going
to output a volume so you'll have one of
these Y outputs for each cell in the
grid that you've partitioned so in this
example there's a 3 by 3 grid and it's a
3 class problem so the output is a
vector of length 8 so the network would
actually I'll put a 3 by 3 by 8 volume
and there's a little bit more math going
on so there's the X and Y's they go
through some Sigma wheedle function in
order to constrain them to be between 0
and 1 because they're they're encoded
relative to where they are within the
cell that they're located in and the
height and width go through like an
exponential parameterization to make
sure that they're greater than 0
they can also be greater than 1 because
they're expressed as
a fraction of the width and height of
the bounding box that their midpoint is
in so the the technique that I'm hinting
at it comes from a paper by Joseph
Redmond ano which stands for you only
look once and the reason this approach
has become so popular is because it
allows you to predict precise bounding
boxes for objects with only passing over
an image once so the some other
techniques that exist require you to
slide over a slide and neural network
over a fixed sized window and make a and
so you're making calculations at each
step whereas with Yolo you only have to
do that once and then there's some other
techniques that involve applying
segmentation algorithms to try to infer
where an object might be I also think
you owe is pretty pretty simple to
understand and I think there's just a
few kind of key concepts that you need
to grasp in order to understand how it
works the first which we hinted on a
hinted at in the last slide our grid
cells and so what you'll commonly see is
you partition an image into like a 19 by
19 grid and then the neural network
outputs this volume and that volume and
that allows you to detect one object per
grid so but what if I want to be able to
detect more than one object for grid
cell so the paper introduces this
concept called anchor boxes and the
intuition behind anchor boxes is let's
say I want to be able to detect five
images in in each cell in the grid well
what you do is you just make the output
five times longer and you would go
through your training examples and you
would pick some shape of an anchor box
that kind of most reflects the the
objects that you're trying to detect and
then that training time you would assign
each example to the segment in the
output that has the most like overlap
with the the anchor box associated with
that segment in the output and what I
mean by overlap is they use a metric
called intersection over Union in order
to do this so intersection over Union is
just meant to measure the overlap
between two bounding boxes so you just
take the area of the intersection
those boxes and divide it by the area of
the union of those boxes now the other
thing that Yolo will do is it'll output
multiple detection for the same object
and you want to be able to clean those
up so it introduces an algorithm called
non-mexican
so what that means is discard all of the
bounding box predictions that have a
confidence of less than 0.6 or some some
hyper parameter of your choosing and
then iterate over the bounding boxes and
focus on the one with the largest
confidence and then discard any other
bounding box that has an iou with that
of greater than 0.5 and this cleans up
the predictions quite nicely along with
this paper they published and they've
open source to pre train network so we
actually perform transfer learning on
top of this network that the paper
published so I'll go into a little bit
of our methodologies for how we've
solved this problem so one of the Yeomen
papers actually proposes this idea of
using unsupervised learning to learn
what your anchor boxes should be instead
of handpicking them i'm so the idea is
take all of your training examples set
them to have the same midpoint and then
for the for the K number of centroids of
your of your choosing cluster in the in
the width and height space and use iou
as the distance metric so we've done
this for three anchor boxes and we're
able to get an average iou of 0.83
whereas some point one would or one
would be perfect the other concept that
we use so it's it's not in the paper but
it is in the open source implementation
it's called warm-up batches I haven't
seen a good theoretical justification
for it but the idea behind it is in the
first few pockets of training
constrained the problem a bit by setting
the bounding boxes to be the same as the
anchor box that it's associated with so
the intuition behind this is it should
help the network familiarize itself with
the data set a bit before trying to work
on a much harder problem and it's been
shown to work in practice so if anybody
has a good theoretical justification for
it I'd also like to hear a bit about
that we use a really small learning rate
which is common with transfer learning
and what we do
is every 40 pox where the loss doesn't
improve
we cut the learning rate in half and
then we trigger early stopping after 70
pox without improvement and then what we
do is after early stopping is triggered
we actually restart training three times
so this is like incredibly inefficient
but what it does is so you bump the
learning rate back up and then you run a
few more warm-up batches and so you'll
see the loss temporarily go back up and
then it'll start going down again what
we've found this does in practice is it
allows the network to explore the lost
surface in a more nuanced way the other
thing that we do is we've experimented
with between ten and twenty percent
negative sampling so we try to include a
few images in the batch that don't have
any detections at all just this is to
see how that affects the results and
we've tried augmenting and enhancing our
data in specific ways as well so in
addition to training on the raw RGB
images we've also used optical character
recognition to apply some enhancements
to the images which I'll tell you about
in the next slide and the other thing
that we've experimented with doing is
constraining the problem to like a
single class a single class problem and
we allow 100 max epochs in practice
though across all three training
sessions we get somewhere between like
60 and 75 total ebox trained so I
mentioned optical character recognition
so optical character recognition is just
extracting text from images we rely on
Google clouds OCR API in order to do
this and that returns these bounding
boxes for every word in an image and
then what we do is we've we've tried to
augment the data in such a way that we
try to highlight words in a document
that appear in close proximity to
signature boxes and Google OCR is also
able to recognize handwriting so we've
like highlighted that as well this is
not really the best example because it's
like it's highlighted signature down
here but it's not anywhere close to a
signature box but I like this example
because you see the model detecting both
signs signature boxes and unsigned
signature boxes in the same image I'm -
the idea behind this is like
higher contrast should make it easier to
detect I'll tell you a little bit about
how we train and deploy these models so
we train on AWS deep-learning a.m. eyes
and we use terraform to orchestrate the
provisioning of the GPU instance and
that provisioner will go and check out
the github repository download all of
the data from s3 and it will spin up a
tensor board server and a jupiter
notebook server that you can log into
and it'll set up SSH and things like
that but you can also kick off the
training of a model without ever SS
aging into the server and then generally
once once a model is done training will
actually just destroy these as well so
we can just spend them up and destroy
them as needed basically so we train
with Kerris with a tensorflow back-end
and then in order to deploy these we
write the wait graph to an s3 bucket and
that gets read into a flask app that's
deployed in AWS Fargate so far gate is
AWS is like container orchestration tool
so we deploy a micro service with that
and that micro service is consumed by
our data processing pipeline so now I'll
jump into our results so some of its
kind of takeaways here are it seems to
us like including two classes actually
so like including signature boxes
actually improves performance on being
able to detect signature boxes so the
classes are so interrelated that the
presence of both helps learn the other
one and then the other thing is these
like manual kind of pre-processing
techniques we've tried it's it's like
unclear if they're actually making a
strong difference like the results are
pretty much the same across both RGB and
OCR so some of the takeaways from this
talk or that so deep learning might not
always outperform approaches that
leverage domain-specific knowledge but
being able to leverage deep learning it
can actually reduce your development
time so you're trading off time spent
applying pre-processing techniques
learning things manually about your data
set and you're exchanging that for time
spent training models so to that if
it can enable your team to produce a
solution faster because you don't have
to handcraft and extract these features
from data you just get to operate on raw
data the other thing is some of the
enhancement approaches that we've
experimented with they don't seem to be
particularly high leverage what we found
to give the best effects was just
labeling more data so by labeling three
times the amount of data that we had
before we were able to get a 20%
increase in recall just by doing that
another thing that we found is that
deploying the weights of a neural
network that operate on raw input can
actually be a lot less time-consuming
than having to port over a
pre-processing code into your
application and the the final thing that
I want to leave you with is you know all
of this being said using deep learning
is not an excuse for not diving into
your data set and building up specific
knowledge of it one of the great things
about these localization networks is
they output these bounding boxes and you
can go back and look at examples and see
what the network is misclassifying what
it's missing and that should infer like
give you some inference on how you
should label data going forward what
your data labeling strategy should be so
in other words if you notice trends
above certain certain objects that
you're missing commonly we'll go back
and label more of those and then include
them in your training set so thanks for
having me feel free to reach out and
contact me I'll hang out a bit we can
talk and I'm happy to take a few
questions now as well thank you any
questions yes
that's a really good question so the
question is what is a bit more about
what our motivation is behind detecting
signatures are we trying to like create
better documents that are easier for
people to remember to sign or are we
just trying to be able to detect things
so that we can send them back I think
it's it's a little bit of both so one of
the things so Zach mentioned in his talk
one of the things we want to be able to
do is standardize more document types
that are used in legal generally that
requires you to be like a dominant
player in in a specific space before you
can kind of set the market but you right
now the primary motivation is it allows
you to filter out drafts because drafts
are commonly unsigned and then being
able to detect unsigned documents
provides legal value to our clients
because we're like a mitigating risk for
them but yeah we definitely don't want
to be like spamming you with unsigned
documents all at once
yes so the question is whether or not
you although is is the best approach to
localizing in documents one of the
reasons I really like UO is is one
because it's it's fast but also because
there are just a lot of good open-source
implementations out there for a lot of
the other ones there it's it's it's a
bit harder to get like grad student code
up and up and running sometimes so yes
yes so that's one of the ones that I
believe correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe that's one of the networks that
applies like a segmentation algorithm
upfront and it tries to infer where
certain objects might be so we looked at
it early on and I think that one of one
of the reasons that we didn't go with
that and we didn't actually evaluate
this empirically but the the theory
being if you're relying on a
segmentation algorithm upfront that
might not work so well when you're
trying to detect the absence of
something so in other words like we're
base and for the unsigned images we're
trying to or the unsigned signatures
we're trying to draw a bounding box in
what is effectively like white space so
that was one of our concerns there so we
didn't evaluate it yes
so that's another one of one of the
things that I really like about Yolo is
you get to do this in a single pass so
it can detect both classes and since
we're so actually what we're doing is
we're treating this as a two class
problem so you know you have signature
boxes and then you have ones that would
contain signatures and ones that don't
contain signatures and those are our two
classes so when I said sometimes that
you signed a signature box and signature
box interchangeably so the way it's
actually set up is we have unsigned
signature boxes and signs signature
boxes those are the two classes that
we're localizing yes
yeah so that's exactly right so we
biased towards having really high recall
because all of this there's a human in
the loop for all of this so a
classification is made and a human is
going to review all of this so what
we've found that the power of machine
learning is in a lot of these cases is
previously the human would be like
combing through a document manually to
find certain things like flipping
through document pages and being able to
have a nice bounding box for something
that you want them to see allows them to
go directly to that and so we'll one of
the things we might want to experiment
with is like what we should do with
different confidence thresholds and like
how we should serve that data but this
has been in production for a very short
amount of time so yeah right right now a
human reviews every document basically
and we want to eventually be able to
either drastically reduce the time that
they spend reviewing documents or being
able to reduce the portion of documents
that they actually have to manually
review so the first one is a bit easier
to reduce the amount of time that they
have to spend yes and not just for
signatures so it'll be for other fields
as well like the counterparty the
effective date yeah and then they can
just click through the suggestions yep
yeah so so that is actually handled by
our implementation so we just use Karis
as like standard data augmentation so
that'll apply like small rotations crops
and it'll do like other kind of like
sharpening and brightening tasks and
things like that so we've we allow like
the Charis library to handle that for us
the manual pre-processing techniques
that we've applied have been trying to
do things with OCR outputs so we've
tried to like create these like high
contrast images that highlight certain
words and documents we've tried to so
the page number like the page number of
a page in a document is that was also
somewhat reflective of whether or not
you would expect a signature because
it's like I think I'm kind of
paraphrasing but I think it's like the
the fourth page of a document is most
likely to have a signature yeah well the
last page but but like across all
documents that's like page four is the
is the most likely but and I'm kind of
paraphrasing that a little bit so I can
other thing we try to do is like shade
the pages based on where they are in a
document
I've seen very few examples of that in
legal documents we are kind of fortunate
that most of the legal documents that we
work with for the tasks that we perform
it's kind of like a fixed space and some
of them are somewhat templated some are
templated more than others but cool well
thanks a lot thanks for having me
[Applause]